Et si je reste et casse une cruche de
le père aznar pose son [ __ ] de problème à
niveau 6 le collectif a été un
tambour et j'ai besoin d'une soirée pizza
politicien qui me représente
mais non
mais
et pourquoi
et la vie en silence nous n'allons pas
permettre un [ __ ] chaque fois qu'il y a
dans notre douleur
ne me dis pas que je vais être en colère non
Je veux tout brûler ils ont tué ma fille
la matula cela ne protège pas
établissements des vallées
[Musique]
Nous vivons dans un pays de fémicide, un pays où
celui que nos morts n'ont pas d'importance
parce que nos corps sont jetables
jetables, nous sommes confrontés à un
situation de terreur très grave où
une guerre a été déclarée contre
femmes aux agressions constantes
que nous vivons et que l'expression maximale de
ces attaques et cette violence sont
fémicide et système judiciaire
Le Mexicain ne cherche pas d'alternatives
qui leur permet d'assister à ce
problématique d'un endroit sensible et
d'un endroit agile où le
la réponse est proportionnelle au nombre de
les féminicides dont vous savez qu'ils ont lieu
vie et le nombre de plaintes
qui existent en matière de violence
genre au mexique
[Musique]
Ouais
nous avons un grave problème d'impunité
les autorités disposent des organes de
les femmes les trouvent mais nous
ils protègent dans les éléments de preuve ce qui
ils le perdent ou le contaminent carrément, ils ne le font pas
ils collectent et cela signifie que vous ne pouvez pas
bien intégrer une enquête préliminaire
que vous n'avez aucun indice et que vous n'avez personne
enquêter et donc
s'il n'y a pas de sanction tu lui passe le message
l'agresseur que tu peux suivre
tuer parce que tu ne le feras jamais
sanctionner la réalité est que le système
le système judiciaire au mexique n'est pas préparé et
n'est pas une formation pour pouvoir
s'attaquer aux féminicides est malheureux
Je pense que toutes les manifestations
de femmes que tous les groupes
collectifs de femmes que tous
organisations civiles et de nombreuses personnes
qui sont aussi dans le
institution et travail à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
nous sommes indignés
nous sommes très frustrés et nous sommes très
en colère parce que nous ne recevons pas
une vraie et vraie réponse
s'occuper des autorités
ce problème si grave que nous vivons
au Mexique